If you're a pet owner, you know how flying can be a rough experience for your dog or cat.
On human airlines, your furry best friend is treated no better than a suitcase,...
...getting stowed away in the uncomfortable and frightening confines of the plane's cargo hold.
Introducing Pet Airways,...
...the world's first airline exclusively dedicated to the safe and comfortable transportation of pets.
At Pet Airways, pets fly in the main cabin, not in cargo.
We believe our pets are not luggage. They're "pawssengers".
On Pet Airways, your best friend travels in four legged style in the main cabin,...
...constantly monitored by a pet attendant with the temperature just right and with lots of fresh circulating air.
Your pet arrives happy and well cared for, and with a lot less stress for both you and your pet.
We should all be so lucky.
Pet Airways, the perfect form of travel for your best friend.
Thank you for visiting PetAirways.com